were you surprised of course you're
surprised but after your character dies
yeah if you haven't seen the show I'm
tough [__] yeah
right off yeah
um what was it 2012. I don't know yeah
whatever
um when this you look you shot it it was
hard it was probably intense yeah you
know it's so [__] up yeah
did you ever think that that scene would
be a tenth as big as what it became no
[__] idea no way no I didn't know any
of it when you saw it before it all came
out and everybody else commented were
you like people are going to be talking
about this one well we started to so
that was the big episode that I was in
and my character had a lot to do and
they started the network started to sort
of talk about the performance and like
it was like people were getting excited
about it so we were invited
to watch it in a room it was me my
managers my agent at the time is Brent
Morley I'll never forget it and we
watched it
and all of us
were on our feet like hands over mouths
[__] energy like we were shocked
we were just shocked and so moved by it
and that was like the coolest [__]
thing I had ever done I was like they
brought your own perform not your but
the experience experience brought you to
your feet I first my agent stood at his
feet and uh I just felt him like stand
up like
and then kind of all of us and I'm kind
of you know when you watch yourself you
have a different experience of it
because I'm like oh when that in this
moment what was actually happening was
this so you're watching it but then you
kind of are able to just like sit back
and enjoy it too I was just so proud to
be like in something cool right it
doesn't always happen I know it never
really can happen never happens never
happens and there's so many people out
there so many actors direct whatever
that they are capable yeah of doing
something but the the things that happen
things gotta line up perfect storm of it
being a great show all eyes are on it
the right director the right Creator the
right props the right ones whatever the
DP the everything comes together to make
this moment and it's never happened I
hate to say it but there's a lot of not
obviously skill but luck yes there's a
lot of luck for all these things to come
together yep a lot of skilled people but
for that to all come together that is
just it's it's miraculous it's one of
the best is ever on on the screen yeah
let alone TV film it whatever it is
um it's crazy I can't I mean it's still
like it's crazy I feel so lucky to have
been a part of something so amazing and
so well done and like they caught
lightning in a bottle did you continue
to watch that show when you were [__]
yeah I'll watch it again I might like
fast forward my scenes a little bit
you know because I'm like oh what am I
doing idiot young and
um but I love the show I I mean yeah I
love it I feel like I could probably
start watching it again tomorrow I need
a show to watch maybe I'll watch
Breaking Bad